herzlich willkommen auf von meiner Seite
zum zweiten Teil
unserer Präsentation zum großen Thema
schreiben neu denken gestern hatte Tina
Werner Wehrhahn ja schon ein schlaglich
geworfen auf schreiben als Instrument
für die fachlehre bzw auch auf die
Schnittmenge die es zwischen der
Fachdidaktik und der schreibtdidaktik so
geben kann und wir werden uns auch nicht
ganz Lösen von diesem von diesen
themenkomplexern eigentlich viel mehr da
immer wieder auch darauf zurückgreifen
heute aber den Fokus noch stärker darauf
legen wie schreiben dann auch als
Forschungsinstrument eigentlich
verstanden werden kann ganz in dem nach
dem Motto writing science ist doing
science
der Präsentation genau klappt wunderbar
wenn man an schreiben und Forschung
denkt dann wird das eigentlich als ein
relativ linearer Prozess häufig
verstanden am Anfang steht die eigene
Forschungstätigkeit wo eben Ergebnisse
erzielt werden Erkenntnisse erlangt
werden und diese Erkenntnisse die werden
zu Papier gebracht und auf diese Art und
Weise erst einmal gesichert
konserviert und dann auch aufbereitet
für ein größeres Publikum und auf diese
Weise können dann diese Ergebnisse die
man in der Forschung erzielt hat auch
größere Verbreitung und ein größeres
Publikum erlangen in dem Sinne ist
eigentlich so das Schreiben eher der
Mittel zum Zweck bzw schreiben wir dann
oft eher so als Medium mehr als Schrift
verstanden auch wenn auch bei diesem
linearen Prozess ist natürlich schon
immer wieder
Zusammenhänge so Interdependenzen auch
gibt das gewisse Teilergebnisse erstmal
zu Papier gebracht werden auf Basis
dieser Teilergebnisse fängt dann die
Forschung vielleicht von Neuem an
vielleicht gewinnt sie neue
Dynamiken oder so also es gibt hier
schon auch
Zusammenhänge auch wenn man es als
linearen Prozess begreift es ist
allerdings ein Stück weit statisch und
wofür wir auch im Laufe des Vortrags
plädieren möchten ist das Schreiben
nicht nur als eben Kommunikations
Element zu sehen sondern dass man
tatsächlich versucht die Methoden der
Schreibdidaktik nutzbar zu machen um die
eigene Forschung voranzubringen um sich
neue Wege zu erschließen wie man auf den
eigenen Forschungsgegenstand selber
begreifen kann das werden viele
tatsächlich auch hin und wieder machen
die eine oder andere Methode ob das dann
brainstorming-listen sind oder ob es
vielleicht auch so kleine Cluster
Mindmap sind oder so die man sich
zurechtlegt die wenden Sie vielleicht
auch schon an vielleicht aber noch nicht
in dem Maße bewusst wie wir es
tatsächlich gerne propagieren möchten
dass das doch ganz gute Idee wäre das zu
tun
genau also es ist tatsächlich eher
Kommunikationswerkzeug innerhalb eines
linearen Prozesses
wenn wir jetzt noch mal auf die Lehre
dann denken damit die Lehre häufig als
etwas verstanden was mehr oder minder
parallel dazu läuft also viele von uns
haben stellen
auf denen sie Forschung betreiben können
und wo sie dann parallel dazu ein
leerbutat zu erfüllen haben oder so die
Lehre ist dann quasi an zweiter Teil der
Anstellung und auch da wird eigentlich
dieser Zusammenhang zwischen Forschung
und Lehre vielleicht in dem Sinne nur
aufgemacht dass gewisse Erkenntnisse die
man erzielt hat in der eigenen
Forschungstätigkeit vielleicht
einfließen in die Lehre Nummer vier aber
wofür wir plädieren möchten ist dass das
ganze eigentlich stärker als ein
Zusammenhang gesehen wird ja also dass
man
Ergebnisse oder auch Dinge die man sich
erarbeitet hat in der Lehre tatsächlich
auch einfließen lassen kann in die
Forschung und das in unserem Fall
konkret bezogen auf die
schreibdidaktischen Methoden die wir
auch gestern schon angerissen hatten da
war ja quasi ein Plädoyer das gewisse
Methoden doch dazu angewandt werden
können die Studierenden zunächst einmal
in Schreiben zu bringen also
überschreibt didaktische Methoden zu
erschließen das erfordert natürlich dass
ich auch die Lehrenden mit diesen
Methoden auseinandersetzen gestern
hatten wir das Beispiel
Gedächtnisprotokoll und da kam mir auch
in der Diskussion auf ja dieses
Gedächtnisprotokoll das habe ich
vielleicht mal irgendwann gesehen hat es
aber gar nicht mehr so präsent muss ich
mir erst einmal anschauen der schließe
ich für mich selbst durch dieses
erschließen und auch Einarbeiten von
diesen schreibtdidaktischen Methoden
fallt man natürlich also bringt man
nicht mehr den Studierenden neue
Fertigkeiten bei neue Möglichkeiten bei
sich Themenkomplex zu erschließen
sondern er arbeitet sich auch selber den
Werkzeugkasten den wir gesehen hatten
und den aber nicht nur für die Lehre
sondern tatsächlich erarbeitet man sich
auch Möglichkeiten und Potenziale die
auch in die Forschung eingehen können
denn quasi gleichsam wie die wie die
Studierenden sich Lehrinhalte
erschließen können durchaus auch auf
Fachebene genauso kann man diese
schreibdidaktischen Methoden auch
anwenden um den eigenen Forschungsstand
Gegenstand zu entfalten also dass man
beispielsweise jetzt nicht nur eine
brainstormingliste Macht sondern von
sich selber mal ein Gedächtnisprotokoll
anlegt dass man für sich selber einen
denkpfad anlegt wie man dann ein
komplexes Forschungs Thema eigentlich
durchsteigen kann und dabei das
Schreiben dann eben nicht nur als
aufschreiben begreift dessen was sofort
zuvor kognitiver erschlossen wurde
sondern tatsächlich als Werkzeug mit dem
der Forschungsgegenstand selbst
neu erfahren werden kann sozusagen und
daher hier diese stärkere Fokus darauf
auf diesen Zusammenhang zwischen
schreiben und Forschung einerseits also
das ist nicht nur in Richtung von dem
Forschungsergebnissen hin zu Publikation
und darüber ist der Weg quasi das
Schreiben sondern eben auch anders das
Schreiben nutzbar machen und sich den
Forschungsgegenstand selbst zu
erschließen das wäre die eine Seite und
die andere Seite ist dass diese
schreibdidaktischen Methoden eben
vermittelt werden können auch nutzbar
gemacht werden können für den eigenen
Forschungsstand das ist plädoy wäre eben
diese Synergien die es dort gibt nutzbar
zu machen und diese verschiedenen
verschiedenen Elemente des
wissenschaftlichen Arbeitens und
Forschung Lehre und Schreiben in dem in
dem Fall als fortlaufend Zusammenhängen
zu verstehen und eben dort die die
Zusammenhänge und die Grenzen die es
gibt ein Stück aufzudröseln und
zumindest die für einen selbst positiven
Elemente die es vielleicht auch in der
in der Lehre gibt die dort sich
erarbeitet haben nutzbar zu machen auch
für die Forschung also Schreiben nicht
nur Kommunikationswerkzeug sondern
tatsächlich als etwas das Impulse
liefern kann für Forschung und Lehre
gleichermaßen hier eben die
schlagwerte während des schreibt denken
und eben die schreibt Didaktik der
nutzbar zu machen
natürlich bleibt der lineare Prozess ein
Stück weit erhalten also es ist schon
klar dass im Endeffekt eine
Forschungsarbeit entstehen soll und da
ist auch ein Teil davon dieser lineare
Prozess allerdings sind eben diese
anderen
diese anderen Zusammenhänge so wichtig
dass wir die eben stärker in den
Vordergrund rücken möchten und eben ein
Stück weit plädieren wollen dafür dass
man hier eben Forschung Lehre als
stärker zusammenhängt die Frage ist wie
macht man das jetzt ja es war jetzt
relativ abstrakt ich habe ja einfach mal
drei Schritte aufgezeichnet wie das
gehen kann wer das erste ist mal eine
Art Bewusstwerdung ja man muss sich
quasi selber als schreibende Person erst
einmal kennenlernen und das funktioniert
eben auch ganz gut darüber dass man mit
den Studierenden auch solche
schreibtidaktischen Methoden einübt weil
darüber man auch immer an sich selbst
quasi diese Methoden mitmachen kann und
dadurch aus sich selbst das schreibende
Person identifizieren kann und da werden
wir auch gleich darauf eingehen was das
für was ist für verschiedene Typen gibt
von Schreibern und inwiefern da
verschiedene Methoden auch sich
besonders gut für die eigen oder anderen
Typus quasi eignen kann also mit dieser
Bewusstwerdung kann man dann auch
schreib Strategien identifizieren und
schreib Strategien mal in dem Fall dann
eben auch wieder Forschungsstrategien
wenn man auch schreibt Methoden dafür
nutzbar machen möchte
damit einhergeht auch eine Reflexion des
eigenen Schreibprozesses also wie gehe
ich eigentlich an einen Schreibprozess
an einem Forschungsprozess heran wie
mache ich das eigentlich gar nichts
heißt alles oder fange ich erst einfach
mal an und guck was dabei rauskommt oder
so also es ist mal diese Bewusstwerdung
Schritt 2 wäre ein Stück weit die
Analyse und da geht es dann darum welche
Stärken und Schwächen stecken eigentlich
so in meinem eigenen streitverhalten
oder in diesem schreibtypus den ich mich
am ehesten nahe sehe und gleichzeitig
auch das Kennenlernen von anderen
schreibtypen also wie machen das
eigentlich andere wie schreiben und
forschen denn meine Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und welche Stärken und
Schwächen kann ich denn da sehen und wo
kann ich mir vielleicht doch was
abschauen und vielleicht
mein eigenes Repertoire noch erweitern
und einfach mehr und vielleicht auch mit
meinen eigenen Routinen brechen oder so
und der dritte Schritt wäre dann die
Nutzbarmachung und das ist dann
eigentlich fast was die Einleitung
vorhin war das Schreiben tatsächlich
auch als Forschungsinstrument zu
begreifen geeignete Methoden für den
eigenen Schreibstil auszuprobieren und
eben mit Methoden bewusst brechen mit
dem eigenen Routinen
wenn wir jetzt mal so an die
verschiedenen schreibtypen und schreib
Strategien denken habe ich jetzt mal
hier vier mitgebracht und vielleicht
erkennen Sie sich auch bei dem einen
oder anderen Typus und dabei ist klar
dass es jeweils so Idealisierungen sind
also die meisten von uns ich habe den
Planer jetzt hier schon aufgemacht
werden nicht striktyp 1 oder Typ 2 sein
sondern eigentlich vielleicht eher sich
dem einen Zyklus nahe sehen und sich
aber auch Elemente von den von den
anderen Typen in sich finden und so ein
Plan in der schreibt hier dieses jemand
der einen vorgegebenen Fahrplan braucht
also es braucht zunächst mal eine feste
Struktur wie eine Gliederung und ohne
diese Struktur kann es eigentlich gar
nicht Anfragen kannst gar nicht losgehen
dieses Projekt also zuerst muss erstmal
klar sein worum geht's und das muss auch
klar sein welche Abfolgen sozusagen
nacheinander kommen und der Vorteil von
so einem Typus wäre eben ein guter
Überblick über das Projekt ein sicherer
Fokus auf die relevanten Inhalte und ein
Konter kann aber sein eine Blockade oder
ein Fest beißen wenn eben die Strukturen
noch nicht ganz klar sind wenn auch
nicht ganz klar sind welche Elemente wie
ineinander fassen oder so
so ein Typus dann hätten wir auch schon
Stärken und Schwächen von diesem Typus
mal dargestellt ein anderer Typus ist
der oder die draußen drauf
losschreiberin ja also erstmal keine
Gliederung machen ich habe hier ein
Thema vor Augen und ich das erste was
ich machen muss ist man irgendwas zu
Papier bringen damit ich quasi in dieses
Thema einsteigen kann es muss quasi
schnell gehen das muss erstmal
assoziativer funktionieren und ein
großer Vorteil dabei ist dass eben
schnell auch Ergebnisse zu Papier kommen
das schreibt denken wird er auch schon
quasi durch den Typus selbst benutzt
also du assoziatives schreiben sind auch
Methoden das schreibt Denkens so ein
Kontra kann natürlich sein dass gerade
bei assoziativen schreiben oder einfach
mal drauflos schreibt auch relativ viel
bei rauskommen wird dass man später
revidieren muss oder wo eben
überarbeitungsschritte notwendig sein
werden also es ist in dem Sinne dann
zeitintensiver wobei auf der anderen
Seite eben auch diese anfangshemmung
durchaus übergangen werden kann durch
diese Methoden die eben dem Typus
drauflosschreiber drauf losschreiberin
Zuge werden
der vierte Typ was sind so
versionenschreiber:innen die produzieren
verschiedene Versionen zu
zu inhaltsabschnitten also dann geht es
dann eine Version A die wir dann eine
Version B gegenübergestellt danach wird
abgewogen welche Version trifft denn das
was ich eigentlich ausdrücken möchte
besser oder schlechter und hier ist ein
Pro beispielsweise ein hoher
Reflexionsgrad
eine eine Städte
Bewusstmachung dessen an was woran man
gerade arbeitet auch eine Städte
Verbesserung von Inhalten mit dem
Nachteil eben das enorm hohen
Zeitaufwands und später eben eine
Auswahl Schwierigkeit von einer 3 sehr
gute Version nebeneinander hat die aber
alle so nur Seat anders funktionieren
muss man sich dann für eine entscheiden
mit seinen Dritter Typus oder eine
Patchworkerin im Patchworker der quasi
parallel an verschiedenen Textteilen
arbeiten kann der mal von hier nach da
springt der sich je nach Stimmung quasi
mal eher der Einleitung zuwendet oder
mal irgendwie dem komplexen Hauptteil
Kapitel je nachdem wo es gerade besser
und dadurch weniger Blockaden hat
flexibel arbeitet aber auf der anderen
Seite auch gegebenenfallslose enden
produziert dadurch dass quasi nicht in
einem Fluss stringent von oben nach
unten geschrieben wird und auch das
Zeitmanagement gegebenenfalls schwierig
ist wenn relativ viel geschwungen
gesprungen wird das sind jetzt einfach
mal vier Typen und so Arten wie man
schreibtypen kategorisieren kann und das
gute ist es gibt auch tatsächlich Tests
die die sie selber machen können und wo
sie da mal schauen können welchen Typus
die sich denn nahe stehen und welchen wo
sie sich quasi am ersten verorten würden
und das jetzt mit diesem schreibdenken
als Forschungsmethode dann noch einher
ginge wäre jetzt quasi eine Analyse
dessen was an dieser Herangehensweise an
Forschungsprojekten denn für sie selbst
positiv ist was da gut funktioniert
warum sie sich eigentlich eher in dem
ein oder anderen Typus sehen und dann
aber vor allen Dingen auch ein bewusst
machen dessen was gegebenenfalls
Schwierigkeiten aufwerfen kann und dann
das schauen über den Tellerrand was ist
eigentlich was könnte eine gute Methode
sein von Patchworker also wenn ich
beispielsweise Planer Planerin bin
vielleicht kann ich einfach mal einen
das Dokument zu machen ein anderes
Dokument aufmachen und einfach mal so
tun als wäre ich drauflos schreibe und
die Methode des assoziativen Schreibens
die diese Person quasi natürlich
anwenden für mich nutzbar machen und das
meint genau diese Integration von
schreibdenken in die Forschung ein
bewusstes nutzbar machen von Strategien
die gegebenenfalls ohnehin auch von
anderen Typen schon gefahren werden oder
die man sich erarbeiten kann und da kann
ich auch noch mal verweisen auf unseren
methodenkasten oder auf diesen die
Methodensammlung Jesus denn dort sind
eigentlich auch Methoden drin die eben
nicht nur für die Lehre funktionieren
sondern eben genauso gut auch für die
Forschung
also man kann mit schreibdidaktischen
Methoden beispielsweise eine
Vorstrukturierung sich arbeiten also
wenn man eher darauf losschreiber ist
und merkt okay ich habe jetzt schon viel
Aufschluss geschrieben ich habe das
Thema für mich eröffnet aber ich komme
irgendwie nicht so recht zurück zu ranne
dann kann ich mir Methoden nutzbar
machen die der Strukturierung dienen und
einfach mal bewusst mit meinem normalen
schreib und forschungsverhalten brechen
mich hinsetzen und beispielsweise ein
Cluster eine Mindmap oder Denkpfade
anlegen und mich danach nachdem ich mir
die Dinge kognitiv zurechtgelegt habe
mir das Ganze sortiert habe wieder
zurückgegeben in meinen natürlichen
schreib habe ich das sozusagen und dann
dort wieder so arbeiten wie ich es
gewohnt bin und trotzdem habe ich mir
eine Methode aus einem anderen Bereich
quasi nutzbar gemacht
eine andere
Anwendungsfall wie Überwindung von
Schreibhemmungen ja also wenn man jetzt
eher ein Planer wäre oder so dann eben
vielleicht nicht zuerst strukturieren
sondern einfach mal anfangen ja das
weiße Blatt überwinden assoziative
schreiben nutzbar machen also ganz
bewusst mit eigenen Routinen brechen und
das eben auch in der Forschung und bei
der Überarbeitung auch sich bewusst
machen dass selbst in diesem linearen
Prozess wenn dann dieses überarbeiten
kommt wo wir alle durch müssen das ist
auch nicht nur darum geht es die
Rechtschreibfehler
auszumerzen und irgendwie die Kommata
richtig zu setzen sondern vielleicht
auch noch mal durch Methoden die es auch
hier gibt das beschreibt didaktischen
schreibgespräch zu führen irgendwie
Fragen an den eigenen Text zu
formulieren oder so den roten Faden sie
schreiben zu erfassen dann noch mal auch
für sich selbst zu hinterfragen ob den
argumentativ der Text denn so gelungen
ist wie wie es gewünscht war oder so und
vielleicht dort auch noch mal
Möglichkeiten nutzbar machen die sonst
vielleicht nicht so präsent waren
und ein möglicher Rahmen dafür wäre die
Schreibgruppe das vielleicht so ein
bisschen mit Blick auf die Zeit als
abschließende als abschließende Idee
oder als abschließende Tipp diese
Schreibgruppen können Sie über das
Schreibzentrum tatsächlich auch
initiieren Schreibgruppen meint dabei
jetzt nicht nur im Sinne von wir müssen
eine Hausarbeit schreiben wir tun uns
zusammen wir treffen uns jeden Tag um 5
und dann schreiben wir alle drei Stunden
sondern es kann natürlich auch genutzt
werden im Sinne von wir setzen uns
zusammen als als forschende und wir
möchten das mal anwenden und wir gucken
mal wie das so bei dem Einen oder bei
der anderen funktioniert und berichten
von unseren Erfahrungen welche Methode
hat gut funktioniert wo bin ich
weggegangen also das war meine
Ausgangsposition was habe ich gemacht
und wie hat das funktioniert und sich so
einfach ein Stück weit auch selbst Motiv
zu motivieren diese neuen Dinge einfach
mal zu probieren und diese
Schreibgruppen wenn Sie das interessiert
dann können sich gerne auch alle
Schreibzentrum wenden auch als Lehrende
da gibt es eine eine Plattform ich
glaube bei Google läuft es die nämlich
nicht alles täuscht über die sich
Interessenten finden können
dann dort eben als Schreibgruppe dann
zusammenarbeiten können tatsächlich auch
eben auch als forschende und als
allerletzter Gedanke noch das will ich
gar nicht im Detail ausführen noch mal
der Hinweis darauf dass eben solche
Methoden zum Beispiel einer denkpfad
oder später auch ein textpfad dass diese
auch im
methodenkasten im in der
Methodensammlung des schreibts auch zu
finden sind und eben auch diese Methoden
für die Forschung nutzbar gemacht werden
kann
vielen Dank